فيما يلي نستعرض بعض ابرز النقاط بشان
جزيره جوان التي تعد من اصغر المناطق
التابعه للولايات المتحده والماهوله
بالسكان في المحيط الهادئ وتبلغ مساحتها
549 كم مربع ترى واشنطن النجوم هي الركن
الاساسي في جبهه الدفاع الامريكيه عند
المحامي المحيط الهادئ وقاعده انطلاق
الجيش الامريكي نحو الصين واليابان
والكوريتين
الجويه مركزا رئيسا لها في جواها اما
البحريه الامريكيه فتتخذ من ميناء قاعده
بحريه لها هناك وذلك للرد على الاختبارات
المتواليه التي اجرتها كوريا الشماليه
لصواريخها الباريستيه وتهديدها المتكرر
بالحرب
ونشر الجيش الامريكيه منظومه الدفاع الجوي
الصاروخيه ثابت في جواام وهي توفر الحمايه
ضد صواريخ البالسكسيه